es geht bei mir um tatsächlich um olaf
scholz und um die regierung stolz wir
haben jetzt schon gehört ich muss gar
nicht bei null anfangen in der ukraine
tobt ein unfassbar blutiger krieg in dem
laut präsident selensky jeden tag
zwischen 60 und 100 ukrainische soldaten
sterben jeden tag dazu kommen etwa
40.000 zivilisten die bislang gestorben
sind auch das kann man jetzt um jedes
100 teilen dann kommt auch auf extrem
wohl zahlen
warum ist das so warum verliert die
ukraine so viele soldaten weil russland
überlegen ist militärisch überlegen ist
weil man eben viel größer als die
ukraine weil man zehnmal so viel
feuerkraft etwa hat und wir sprechen
hier von schweren waffen das heißt was
braucht die ukraine auch schwere waffen
um sich zu wehren deutschland sagt okay
wir machen das ich zitiere olaf scholz
vom ersten juni wir senden der ukraine
seit kriegsbeginn waffen auch schwere
waffen auch schwere waffen ist eine
glatte lüge es gibt keine einzige
deutsche schwere waffe oder aus
deutschland gesendete schwere waffe in
der ukraine stattdessen macht olaf
scholz das so dass er sagte machen
ringtausch ringtausch ist ein total
spannende idee hört sich erst mal total
interessant an die idee dahinter ist so
sagt die bundesregierung ihr in
osteuropa oder südeuropa gibt der
ukraine die alten sowjetischen waffen
und dafür kriegt ihr von uns die
modernen deutschen waffen das hat zwei
haken erste haken ist diese modernen
deutschen waffen ist genau das was die
ukraine möchte was sie angefragt hat
seit erster märz und nichts davon
bekommen hat und die zweite haken haben
wir es gerade für sich gesehen in
griechenland da haben die griechen
nämlich erst mal gesagt na gut dann gebt
ihr uns 50 moderne marder panzer und die
kriegen dann 50 alte nva panzer von der
nationalen volksarmee aus der ddr aber
ihr müsst uns erst die mahler liefern
die müssen auf jeder einzelnen insel in
der ägäis ankommen und erst dann holen
wir unsere ur alten sowjet altmetall
dort weg und schicken das in der ukraine
und die griechen haben gesagt das können
wir machen das dauert ungefähr zwei
monate ab da wo eure waffe hier sind
also ab in zwei oder drei monaten
klartext olaf scholz mit diesen ring
tauschen startet er nicht etwa die
ukraine mit schweren waffen aus sondern
erhält enthält die schwere waffen vor in
dem fall jetzt sowohl die deutschen
magath jetzt wechselt vom markt die
gehen alle nach griechenland als auch
die griechischen schützenpanzer auch
wenn die 30 40 50 jahre alt sind die
ersten drei oder vier monaten überhaupt
der ukraine ankommt dann kann es schon
zu spät sei
darf ich eine frage militärexperten an
der stelle stellen also ich kann ja über
olaf scholz nicht sagen ich kenne und
eine neutrale ist erreicht wir liefern
ja nur splitter westen und und
stahlhelme und das auch nur für den
katastrophenschutz aber sie haben gesagt
du möchte anschließen was gesagt wird
über das plattmachen und die ukraine
brauchen diese unterstützung vor allem
schwere waffen die dann auch als
offensivwaffen gelten schwierige
definitionsfrage ist ja ich geb dir
reden in erster linie über kaliber die
größe 115 um sozusagen da der artillerie
überlegenheit der russen etwas
entgegensetzen zu können und sie auf
distanz zu halten aber was ist denn das
wenn man das macht
und wenn man dann eine eine kriegspartei
nämlich den angegriffen in dem der das
selbstverteidigungsrecht hat bei dem er
immer auch unterstützen muss trotzdem
kommt nicht umhin als kriegspartei sowie
ein kriegsziel zu das fand ich sehr
interessant dass zu beginn die
ukrainische position war es gibt so sie
einen verhandlungsfrieden unter der
grundlage dass die positionen von vor
dem 24 februar eingenommen werden
zwischendurch gab es die position man
kann erst über einen waffenstillstand
und einen dauerhaften frieden reden wenn
die territoriale integrität der rede
wieder hergestellt ist das heißt der
komplette doch das ohne große
stattlichen und auch die green
zwischendurch hatte man den eindruck
nachdem also bei kiew die ukrainische
truppen bis in die russische grenze
vorgestoßen sind drei tage später sind
sie wenn sie wollen unter westen sie
unterstützt eigentlich schon in moskau
also es gibt immer sehr unklare
nachrichtenlage
verkauft worden ist wahrscheinlich die
experten und ich habe immer gewundert
dass das dann in den westlichen medien
auch in den lageberichten immer eins zu
eins übernommen wurde und ich mir denke
bin ich jetzt die letzten drei wochen
zurückblicke dann müsste man eigentlich
ja schon irgendwie den eindruck kriegen
moment möglicherweise müssen wir dann
irgendwie doch zweimal hinschauen
nämlich einerseits was die tatsächliche
lage auf dem schlachtfeld bin
offensichtlich nicht immer sehr genau
einschätzen können und zweitens auch
wenn ich mich an einem krieg beteiligen
und das tun wir als westen und ich würde
sagen dass guten gründen weil wir den
angegriffenen helfen dann muss man ja
ein ziel damit verfolgen und dieses ziel
ist nach wie vor unklar also ich halte
das für ziel für relativ klar sie haben
das relativ er vereinfacht aber richtig
gesagt die genannten marken was heißt
plattmachen plattmachen hat selensky
heute noch mal gesagt ich glaube bei der
von policy im interview hat das gesagt
dem magazin platt machen heißt für ihn
erstmal alles auf den stand vom 23
februar zurück bewegen und über alles
andere können wir danach sprechen das
heißt ich gehe nicht davon aus dass es
in linz geht die krim zurückerobern will
das ginge auch gar nicht weil die ist
relativ einfach zu schützen die ukraine
hat überhaupt gar keine eigene marine
die russen haben sehr großer marina auch
der dornbach obwohl man natürlich
zweifelsfrei sagen kann das ist ein
ukrainisches gebiet hat sony heute
nochmal gesagt nein das wollen wir nicht
zurückkam wir wollen am 4 aber natürlich
unser ganzes land befreien irgendwann
militärisch war es auf dem stand vom 23
februar zurückkriegen diesen jahres und
das wollen wir mit militärischen mitteln
schaffen das heißt diese militärische
mittel braucht er hat er aktuell nicht
um die russen zurückzutreiben sie haben
gefragt wie denn so was geht ja man hat
auch nicht geglaubt im ganzen märz als
der russe ja wir haben gesagt ein in
kiel war vor kiefer überall um das land
herum bei dem ganzen norden war da hat
man auch gerade oder ist schon fast
vorbei da ist noch zwei tage ja ich
erinnere mich immer der merkel berater
und ein hoher general general erich
vater gesagt es gibt ja ukrainer noch
eine woche dann ist die sache gegessen
plötzlich am 31 märz sind nacheinander
monaten krieg fast sind 40 40.000 sich
herum gehört gezogen und bekommt
dann hat man gesagt im osten der ukraine
also so ein hafen dort aus die ukraine
haben jetzt eigentlich das umgedreht die
russen sind knapp vor dem ende seinen
nachschub das war ein fehler anstatt
also die ganze truppe schlecht und die
kriegen nicht im funkverkehr hin und
sind alle zu schnell unterwegs wissen
gar nicht wo sie sind haben abgenommen
eins zu eins und dann wieder drei wochen
später hieß es die ukraine ist
eigentlich im osten die jetzt wenn da
nicht jetzt schnell noch was kommt also
das ist dann doch der verdacht sehr
naheliegend und das ist nicht verdacht
im sind das aber schlimmes passiert aber
es ist doch relativ eindeutig dass wir
hier im westen auch in unserer
berichterstattung viel zu oft eins zu
eins die die die hand zu einer sache
dass man ein europa der sache dazu sagen
dann über die eine partie auf jeden fall
bitte ich will muss sagen es haben das
ist nicht die propaganda sondern die
russen haben am anfang gedacht dass sie
kaum widerstand kriegen und sind mit
ihren panzern hunderte kilometer
geradeaus gefahren und haben nicht
gemerkt dass hinter ihnen die tanklaster
zerschossen werden das haben sie
geändert seit sie aus volkach abgezogen
haben sie das komplett geändert sie
gehen langsam vor stück für stück sie
haben auch jetzt in letzten zwei monaten
gerade mal 20 kilometer gut gemacht und
nicht 200 jahren ersten tag insofern ist
das eine andere taktik die sie anwenden
und insofern finde ich auch richtig wenn
wir darüber anders sprechen manchmal
hernals bürger wenn sie hören platt
machen wenn sie die debatte hier
verfolgen
schrecklich letztendlich weil genau wie
er das sagt es sind menschen leben die
da natürlich jeden tag schicksale die
man hört wie das leben verlieren
nichtsdestotrotz muss man natürlich
schauen wie ich habe sie bei einem
plakat sagen welchen stand muss man
einsehen und kann entsprechend dann
dafür sorgen dass es zu einem ende hin
kommt und nicht dieses ja wie weit gehe
ich noch und welchen medien kann ich das
glauben die das propagieren also ich
finde es schwierig da durch zu blicken
und es ist halt ja nicht nur eine
richtige wahrheit das thema gerade wenn
es auch um preispolitik et cetera geht
wie deutschland momentan sehr sehr stark
darunter wenn ich dann höre dass auf dem
ozean sich dann die die entsprechenden
schiffe treffen und dann wird russisches
öl umgeladen und verkauft über indien
das heißt er putin freut sagt er macht
sein geschäft seines lebens die in der
haben guten zusatz zusatzeinnahmen und
wir als deutsche zahlen momentan den
höchsten preis dafür gefühlt treffen die
sanktionen eigentlich momentan die
falschen und das ist einfach doppelt
traurig war möchte mit den sanktionen
eigentlich dafür sorgen dass das
irgendwie beendet wird ich habe das
gefühl es gibt viel zu viele
schlupflöcher das stimmt bislang ist die
russische wirtschaft nach stabil
ökonomen prophezeien aber dass die
russische wirtschaft noch einbrechen
wird also dass man es nicht halten kann
dass die sanktionen noch stärker wirken
werden da muss man schauen wie es in der
zukunft absolut klappen wird also sie
sagen auch man sollte hat er bei tags
letztlich muss man schauen dass man zu
einem ende kommt das ist glaube ich dass
das wichtige und da ist momentan ja sehr
schwierig und ja wirklich nebel in dem
ganzen berichterstattung wir waren da
hört zu schauen wo kriege ich wirklich
ein punkt hin klar dass drohgebärde
gegen absolut recht zu sagen man hätte
viel früher stärker auftreten müssen
jetzt ist ja die frage was reicht um da
ein stillstand zu bekommen habe vor
allen dingen nicht das volk belügen ja
sagen wir liefern im juni wir liefern
juli beliefen bush war mich gestern war
mich heute warum nicht sofort liefern
der beleuchtet werden können und den
stillstand sehe ich doch gar nicht an
wenn so viele menschen geworden sind so
viel ist so viel elend des strapazierten
stillstand das wäre doch das wäre doch
nicht richtig wir sind und wir müssen da
kämpfen einfach wir müssen das mal der
krieg muss beendet werden da muss
beendet werden von der ukraine und von
den europäern wir brauchen das wir
wissen dass alle waren wir müssen alle
zusammenhalten und die deutsche
regierung belegt das volk wir liefern
wir liefern und nicht wird geliefert
wird er gar nicht gemacht die deutschen
haben es ja warum tut es nicht warum tun
sie sich warum tun sie es nicht sofort
warum müssen noch mehr menschen leiden
und starb das frage ich mich haben ein
händchen würde ich gerne einmal nach
ecken sind sie denn davon überzeugt dass
wenn diese waffen geliefert werden dass
damit der krieg beendet wird ja da haben
doch nicht nach und gewalt wenn die
waffen geliefert werden wer mir alles
liefern hat er dort liefern würde dann
hätte ich ja kritischen will zu ende
dann ist der krieg schnell zu ende juli
japanische wirtschaft sagen
also auf jeden fall schneller als jetzt
also wir sehen hat dass das nochmal die
übrigen wenn wir jetzt liefern dann wird
der krieg beendet genau die hat ihre
könnte sind die unterstützen ich glaube
zahlreiche militärs fragten sagen dass
diese sieben panzerhaubitze 2000 an dem
wir gerade ausbilden und deutschland
immerhin kommen zusammen mit fünf
holländische sind 12 12 stück da sagen
viele das tut den russen schon wie toll
studien tatsächlich wie 120 würden die
russen in einem monat besiegen wurde in
der ukraine wird es keine russen mit
gegen 120 von diesen geschützten die
sind absolut präzise die können pro
minute sechs schuss abgeben und zwar
genau 40 kilometer entfernt auf eine
person da werden sicher an mir ich mache
mir aber nicht und das ist vollkommen
richtig wir scheinen eher zu sagen na ja
so ein bisschen damit es nicht bis ganz
zu uns kommt oder nach kiew aber wir
gucken uns das lieber noch weiter an
denn und das ist ja die interessante
idee von herrn scholz ich telefoniere
weiter mit herrn putin ich versuche
weiter eine verhandlungslösung zu
schwimmen ist das nicht sinnvoll
diplomatie aufrechtzuerhalten um den
krieg auch zu bayern mit jemandem der st
akt die ukraine muss als kultur als
nation als volk ausgelöscht werden
beiseite schweiz machen ihn ignorieren
nicht mehr dran gehe ich auch versucht
an ich glaube nicht dass herr putin auch
nur ein einziges mal angerufen hat seit
kriegsbeginn
mit herrn putin kontakt hat ich bin nie
gegen dialog aber es muss einen dialog
sein der aus einer starken position
kommt ein dialog der sagt wenn ganz klar
wir sprechen darüber ihr könnt euch
zurückziehen wenn ihr das nicht macht
festsetzen wir die ukraine in die lage
klar zu machen in der ukraine russland
diallo erfolgreich denn die diplomatie
aufgeben den dialog ich glaube es geht
ohnehin die es ist immer schlecht oder
nicht wir reden ist immer schlecht es
gibt dann viele die sagen und das kann
man gut nachvollziehen solche gespräche
kann vor allem der angegriffene nur
führen aus einer position der stärke in
der also man sagt die interessante frage
der militärexperten beendet eigentlich
der verlierer den krieg oder beendet der
sieger den krieg aber das ist mir
vollkommen klar dass man dass man
jemanden der angegriffene dabei
unterstützen muss sich selbst zu
verteidigen dann werden die dynamik die
prozesse dynamisch also ich bin mir
nicht sicher ob das so schnell geht und
sagt wenn die nicht zwölf solche
haubitzen haben sie nur 20 da gibt es
keinen russischen soldaten mehr in der
ukraine ich glaube man hat das gefühl
man hat ja schon oft darüber berichtet
die wissen gar nicht mehr was sie mit
dem ganzen gelieferte material machen
sollen es ist so viel dann ist man
draufgekommen so wie jetzt bei den oder
bei den panzern aus polen es ist gar
nicht so einfach mit dem nachschub weil
die russischen streitkräfte immer noch
dazu in der lage sind die nachschubwege
verzug und militärgerät wird nun mal auf
gleisen geliefert relativ konsequent und
auch präzise zu unterbrechen also ich
wäre vorsichtig mit diesem wenn dann und
wenn das nicht zwölf sondern zehnmal
soviel dann gibt es über kurz oder lang
einen russischen soldaten endokrine da
wäre ich da würde ich sagen da wäre also
wurde zu recht gesagt habe ich vom markt
genommen sind schwierig besonders wenn
sie die zukunft betreffen
aber ich meine es geht ja nicht darum
jetzt die ausstellung soll da haben alle
platt zu machen in der ukraine sondern
liefern um abzuschrecken man kann ja
abschreckend vielleicht hielt er sich
zurück aber
wir brauchen das ja nicht wir brauchen
den gleichen gesetzen wenn aber wenn ich
weiss waffen werden liefert und waffen
sind
aber das ist doch dass da reden sie es
doch von zwei sehr unterschiedlichen
dingen und ich glaube dass abschreckung
wesentliches momentum ist in jeder
bewaffnete auseinandersetzung
wahrscheinlich vor allem vor einer
bewaffneten auseinandersetzung aber ich
glaube wenn wir sagen fünf sagen wir
müssen jetzt sehr emotionalen und das
moralischen gründen die russen
plattmachen und fünf minuten später
sagen wir es geht nur darum die in die
lage zu versetzen abzuschrecken dann
glaube ich ist es nicht wahnsinnig
konsistent ehrlich gesagt na also ich
finde da ich finde das vollkommen
richtig ich spreche hier also dadurch
werde vollkommen richtig werden die
waffe da stand man kann den feind
schrecken man kann in abschreckt und
gerade okay jetzt jedes zurück sonst
knallts das kann man machen in der
ukraine ist ja nix der russe kann ja
beide kennen und machen und tun ist ja
nix da die ukraine haben ja nichts aber
wenn wir mal liefern wenn wir richtig
liefern wir europäer und zeige den
russen jetzt geht's los jetzt geht zur
sache dann ziehen die sich vielleicht
zurück dass man das muss man eingehen
das muss man machen muss es papiere
nicht heute und nicht morgen und im abo
auch im kalten krieg gelernt und überall
in der militärstrategie abschreckung ist
per se ein begriff und wenn man so will
eine politische strategie die vor dem
beginn des militärischen konflikts
interessant jahre militärische konflikt
läuft dann können wir heute haben wir ja
sagen bleibt machen da kann nicht beides
gleichzeitig du bist du der du hast ja
durch unbedingt für intelligent halten
vielleicht studiere ich vielleicht haben
die russen wie alle anderen menschen und
verteidigen doch nicht ich mache das
schon ganz groß was ist was ich sagen
würde ist tatsächlich die us army macht
tolle fotos auf social media von jeder
waffe die sie liefern und wie die sie
eingeladen wurde das flugzeug die sie
ausgeladen wird wie man damit trainiert
die bundesregierung sagt wir machen das
alles geheim wir können auf den
journalisten ich sagen wann wo was genau
darüber geht damit geht der
abschreckungseffekt völlig weg die
amerikaner wirklich zeigen dass und ich
sehe dass in der russische propaganda
die haben angst davor die sagen oh oh oh
oh was mit den westafrikanern oder
trommel ich dann müssen wir mal
aufgegangen ob die ihn sich zurückziehen
weil sie nicht aber es hat einen
psychologischen effekt auf die zusagen
ab jetzt haben wir angst dass in der
region attraktiv oder donuts dass jetzt
diese bösen neuen amerikanischen waffen
da sind von den deutschen hören sie bloß
also wir sagen keinen ob da überhaupt
etwas hingeht und ich finden tatsächlich
dieser effekte abschreckung geht
verloren bei unserer politik